hello everyone and welcome to a video of
learning as there weren't any um
suggestions over the past couple of days
regarding what content to show of what
was happening in the Chess World and we
are waiting for the Tata still to
commence uh I decided to show you a nice
way on how to checkmate with uh King and
Knight and of course you know from
experience that that should not be
possible and you are correct if black
for example in this case if black only
has a king and no pawns no pieces then
white is unable to checkmate with King
and Knight point being that G1 and G2
are covered by the king and the Knight
covers the H2 Square so the best de you
can do uh is to stalemate the black king
you would also need something that
actually delivers check on H1 to deliver
Checkmate and if the Knight is on F2
delivers check then the king can escape
to H2 so while it's not possible to
Checkmate um with your with your king
and Knight exclusively it is possible if
black has at least one Pawn or maybe two
pawns or maybe even more material so I'm
going to show you uh three simple
positions that are basically the same
thing only uh well they they can happen
sort of through a different position or
a different move order so this is uh the
elementary position where black gets
checkmated by uh by the White Knight and
if you show this to someone who isn't
really good at chess who wins this uh
they'll probably say black wins this
because you just push the pawn check the
white king and promote the pawn to a
queen they know that it is impossible to
check me to with only a king and Knight
but here the way you win this is uh by
going Knight to F6 and then only well
now okay black can choose between G5 and
King H1 doesn't really matter if King H1
you're going to go Knight to G4 sorry
about that and you're going to go for
the standard setup that we are going to
use to Checkmate the black king in all
of these positions so King to F1 uh
you're going to force H2 and down Knight
to F2 will be Checkmate that's how you
do it and it doesn't matter if instead
of King to H1 G G5 is played again the
same thing Knight to G4 with check King
to H1 King to F1 forcing the H Pawn to
move it is the only move for black and
once H2 is played the black king is
completely boxed in and now Knight to F2
uh will be Checkmate so it's the same as
in the previous one that we covered if
we had the Knight on F2 only now the
king cannot go to H2 as there is a Pawn
on H2 so that's the idea and uh using
that one we can solve pretty much um uh
any uh such position where not all of
them are of course possible to Checkmate
uh but for example this one again
similar we have to get the same position
like in the previous one we're going to
go Knight to G3 with check uh or also we
could just play King to F2 and now after
King H2 Knight to C3 and we have to get
our uh Knight to to F1 to deliver check
with Tempo we have to put a knight on F1
with check to force the King on H1 uh
and then it's going to be Checkmate so
here King to H1 will be played Knight to
E4 King to H2 Knight to D2 and now after
King to H1 at Knight to F1 not the not
the deliver check but to prevent the
king from going to H2 and forcing Pawn
to H2 which will be the only move black
will have and now Knight to G3 will be
Checkmate and it's the exact same thing
is if we start with Knight to G3 check
instead of going for King to F2 King to
H2 will be played again Knight to E4
King to H1 black only has two moves King
H2 and King to H1 King to F2 now we move
the king king H2 Knight to D2 and now
King to H1 you're basically using this
King to D2 uh King F1 King to F2
maneuver uh to win that crucial Tempo
you need to play Knight to F1 while the
king is on H1 and now black is again
forced to play H2 uh and Knight to G3
will be Checkmate which brings us to the
third position uh where black has two
pawns but they are not connected so one
is on the f file one is on the H file
now how do you win this uh using all of
uh the the ideas that you've seen now
how do you force the exact same thing
from this position have at it while I
give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
figuring out that it's the ex exact same
position and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Knight to
E5 uh this is the movie you have to play
now it would be uh it would be a poor
choice to go King to F2 probably the
only two moves that you considered
Knight E5 or maybe okay you considered
some other Knight jobs but also you
consider King to F2 King to F2 would not
work because after King H2 uh sorry not
after King H2 after Pawn to H2 uh and
now you move the Knight because black is
tail mated otherwise black will play F3
and you cannot take it if you take with
the King then the black king escapes if
you take with the Knight it's still mate
and after King to F1 you will play F2
white will have to capture and it's
still mate so the only move that allows
you to play this for a win H is Knight
to E5 none of the other Knight jumps
will work here uh King to H2 and now
King to F2 now we uh use this to win a
Tempo King to H1 or F3 doesn't even
doesn't really matter we're going to
play Knight to G4 uh and after Pawn to
F3 we're going to play King to F1 uh
Pawn to F2 now giving up the pawn Knight
captures an F2 check King H1 and now
Knight to E4 uh we basically get the
position from the previous video as the
G3 square is now covered by the Knight
and the only Move That Remains for black
is the H1 Square so King H1 will be
played King F2 and now it's exactly the
same King H2 Knight to D2 we're going to
play King to H1 Knights to F1 only move
Pawn to H2 because the black king cannot
go to H2 and after H2 Knights to G3 will
be Checkmate uh so yeah that's uh that's
the stuff there you have it uh you
cannot checkmate your opponent with only
a king and Knight but if your opponent
has a pawn two pawns three pawns eight
pawns uh it is very much possible uh so
that's the that's the the the video hope
you guys enjoyed it I would like to wish
a very happy birthday to Caroline a and
I would like to thank Anna Pano Robert
kefir Welsh fan and Frank PL for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check out two of my previous videos
here thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happen s in the Chess
World uh so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day